oh
longtemps au pied du perron de la maison
ou en tram adam que j'avais suivi
pendant deux bonnes heures amsterdam ça
marche et voix
en juin
vous êtes sûr que vous voulez faire ce
film on va prendre un ton papa très
sérieux de mai à juillet 2004 jean-louis
trintignant quitte sa région des
cévennes deux jours par semaine pour
jouer à paris
il est l'interprète des poèmes à lou de
guillaume apollinaire
il arrive de dimanche midi pour jouer à
15h donnent deux représentations le
lundi est presque aussitôt s'enfuit vers
le calme de sa compagne c'est au théâtre
de la madeleine que s'est construit ce
film de rendez vous en rendez vous de
répétition en répétition il était une
fois un poète en boel qui parti de la
guerre on ne sait pas pourquoi
voulez-vous être aimé n'aimait pas
croyez-moi il mourut en disant ma
comtesse je t'aime et j'ai voulu à
travers le petit jour si froid les obus
s'envoler comme l'amour lui même
j'ai dû faire 25 films avant 27 je crois
avant un homme et une femme qui m'a
permet de passer à un autre échelon
mais jusque là je faisais des films où
j'étais sûrement moins bien payés que
les machinistes et aux électriciens des
films j'avais tourné dans et dieu créa
la femme n'en avait pas remarqué
non c'était brigitte bardot surtout été
remarquable
enfin la jeunesse et quelques-uns et
savait jamais c'est à dire que j'étais
un comédien sérieux mais pas j'étais
payé vraiment des misères je trouvais
que c'était bien mais c'était pas
pourquoi ces termes ont très peu et à
partir de nommer une femme je suis
devenu un comédien oui sur qui on
pouvait monter un film un comédien
important ce qui était intéressant c'est
que c'était un film un peu d'amateurs
c'est un petit film il y avait je crois
si personne pour faire le film
c'est à dire que tout le monde faisait
un peu tout lellouche était metteur en
scène il avait écrit le scénario et il
tenait la caméra et il avait un
opérateur un chef opérateur qui
s'appelait pouget patrick pouget c'était
un grand type costaud il n'y avait
jamais la caméra sur pied c'était
toujours lui se baladait caméra isight
et des fois quand ils voulaient faire un
un panorama ou un travelling il faisait
un truc de et patrick pouget savez il se
mettait entre ses jambes et il portait
et puis il fait faire des mouvements
c'est pour dire que c'était vraiment y
ait pas lumière y est un projecteur ni
rien alors parfois quand y avait pas
assez de lumière il tourné en noir et
blanc parce que la pellicule est plus
sensible était peut-être moins
maintenant mais étaient plus sensibles
en noir et blanc
voilà c'est pour dire que c'est un film
vraiment mais artisanale artisanale
c'était amusant ça me plaisait
énormément nous les acteurs on faisait
le clap avant que le la prise on faisait
le clap
et puis on se mettait en place et en
soirée notre scène c'était vachement
sympa mais il ya des choses dans le film
qui sont bien il ya une spontanéité il
ya une fraîcheur
il ya une même une naïveté qui est joli
et puis il ya un goût du cinéma
1 c'est vrai c'est un goût du cinéma
quand même
est ce que vous pouvez imaginer ici
blocs et bâillonné avec ce téléphone qui
n'arrête pas de sonner et toutes ces
rumeurs dans la rue bien sûr votre passé
de l'excès de zèle
je sais que vous avez fait tout ça pour
me rendre service n'hésitez à moins de
mener leurs enquêtes à nice et que c'est
elle ou pas soyez certains que je
n'aurais rien fait pour vous si j'avais
su que vous étiez un assassin oui je
sais tout il ya trois jours vous avez
chargé un détective de nice de faire une
enquête sur votre femme
mais demain je n'ai pas bougé d'ici oui
vous l'avez commander par téléphone et
en vous gardant bien de révéler votre
identité
cela prouve que vous aviez déjà les
soupçons sur marie christine ferber un
peu entre nous je peux vous le dire
maintenant j'ai toujours su que vous
étiez un assassin même si je faisais
semblant de croire votre or mauvais
temps je croyais que c'était un crime
passionnel commis en pleine colère par
un homme sincère et déchiré en réalité
vous avez tout calculé tout prémédité et
ça ça m'inspire le plus profond des
gouffres
si je me retenais maman papa vous avez
raison j'aurais dû vous avouer la vérité
tout de suite je suis coupable
il était très très sympathique autres
faux je vais rencontrer une fois par
exemple dans un festival où on était
juré je crois tous les deux et je lui ai
parlé je lui ai dit c c'est étonnant que
j'ai jamais que vous vous ayez jamais
demandé voilà et j'ai eu des parce que
j'aurais pu très bien faire jouer dans
vos films ça me convenait très bien
d'ailleurs j'en ai fait qu'à et j'étais
je les fais vraiment le pen dans le mayo
facile parce que sa façon de parler
parce que tout tout tout m'était facile
quoi ce n'était pas très intéressant
d'ailleurs ce que je faisais mais c'est
j'ai eu quand même beaucoup de plaisir
ils étaient légers ils étaient s'était
jamais grave s'était jamais il aimait
bien j'aime beaucoup et je les ai connus
à une période vraiment je sais pas s'il
a tout le temps été comme ça mais
c'était une période où j'ai commencé à
être confortable mais son confort
s'était pas
accumuler le fric c'était 2 ils
voulaient rendre la vie légère à tout le
monde par exemple
normalement un tournage c'est huit
heures par jour
mais lui il préférait qu'on fasse 6h et
puis de renvoyer les gens après quoi
d'aller boire des coups avec il arrêter
le tournage avant alors qu'il était en
même temps producteurs quoi c'était son
frais que s'ils avaient vraiment voulu
faire davantage de free qui l'aurait
fait travailler les gens jusqu'au bout
tandis que là il disait en me maintenant
vous êtes fatigué il faut arrêter
c'était vachement agréable
j'ai fait un tour sur le plateau je
reviens rester
pour mes valises sur cette partie là et
essayer quelque chose ça peut être pour
l'accordéon quelque chose d'un peu peu
église et ça fait un peu peut-être ce
rôle mais mais mais pour faire sonner
comme un orgue sur le jeu même si je
voulais pas si méchant mais je dirais je
lis moi ne pas voir psg tweet
non je ne crois pas que ça à faire
double emploi oui c'est cher plus on est
assez bien fait hier parce que j'ai fait
un break chendo sur le web cette baisse
met fin à la présente à tue tête en
decrescendo lycée
là je voulais tu mettais en scène je
voulais pas être acteur c'est marrant ça
n'a jamais eu tellement plus il ya
quelque chose il ya des choses qui me
plaisent dans le métier d'acteur de
signer mais un plein de choses qui me
déplaisent qui m'ont toujours des plus
qu'ils n'ont toujours déplu oui je
trouve que c'est fait un peu c'est un
peu trop fait comme de la conserve comme
un truc quand même très travaillée
appliquée on peut recommencer on peut
même l'idée me plaisait pas tellement et
les premiers films que j'ai fait c'était
ça m'a vraiment consolider dans l'âme
piètre idée que j'avais du métier
d'acteur
j'aurais bien remplie c'est l'histoire
d'un type qui se lèvent le matin il ya
une unité de temps ça se passe en une
journée
et c'est un boulanger du gard il fait
son plein comme tous les matins et puis
il part avec sa vieille mère en
side-cars et avec des accessoires tout
ça et puis commence à rouler et ils vont
tuer une personne
et puis il roule il en tue un antre et
itunes 9 personnes c'est-à-dire les
durées de la cour d'assises guian
condamné son fils à mort
leur seule chance et qu'on ne comprenne
pas le lien qu'il peut y avoir entre ces
gens là il faut faire très vite
mais finalement ils fous pourquoi le
dernier jour
c'était un truc contre la peine de mort
je voulais que
les jurés qui qui condamne et qui
condamnait à mort à ce moment-là
ne prenez jamais le risque quoi ça leur
coûtait rien finalement
et pour une fois les jurés c'est leur
coûter la vie quoi se faisait tuer parce
qu'ils avaient condamnés à man c'est pas
sérieux mais c'est une
c'est une femme l'enfoncer mais c'était
il y avait des choses quand même pas mal
je voulais faire une chose je voulais
pas faire de leur accord vous savez
aussi humain on tourne par exemple un
plan sur un personnage sur un autre et
puis en créant un plan général et là je
ne veux pas faire ça
j'avais souvent deux caméras caméras
c'est parce qu'ils coûtent cher mais je
voulais paquet de raccord je voulais pas
que les acteurs refasse la scène avec un
autre objectif dans un autre angle je
voulais qu'ils tournent la scène une
fois épique après une île n'est pas à
raccorder quand il n'est pas à la
tournée ça c'était un peu une
frustration d'acteurs parce que ça m'a
jamais plu de faire l'acteur ou jeu
tournait une scène où je me déchirait et
puis après je devais faire la même chose
sous un autre angle quoi je je trouve
que si on se donne vraiment dans une
scène c'est ce que j'aime au théâtre
c'est que on n'a pas à leur faire quoi
je l'aï dit ça parce que vous voyez
maintenant mais si vous l'aviez connus y
avait un temps été comme vous et moi
attenti prêt à rendre service
charmant drôle
facétieux légèrement gourmande mais
c'est pas une raison pour ôter il a
réussi c'est normal il profite de son
argent il peut tous non plus vous dire
je vais vous dire une chose monsieur
marcel et à paralyser des gens comme il
a des moyens
il n'a pas de raison de marchés vous
comprenez si vous est-ce que vous
n'aviez le maître nageur
c'était un petit film avec des amis
producteurs et ans m'avait donné une
caméra c'était une lomas s'appelait la
louma j'avais écrit vraiment tout le
film pour ça et une moitié du film ça se
passe et nous ici alors avec cette
caméra on pouvait s'approcher de
quelqu'un on pouvait et puis j'ai tourné
trois jours comme ça et après on m'a
enlevé la caméra parce que les
producteurs qui avait pas beaucoup de
fric et il avait eu parce qu'elles
n'étaient pas utilisés personnes
employées et puis il ya eu un grand
metteur en scène américain qui l'a
demandé c'était spielberg
il me l'enlever et à ce moment là tout
ce que j'avais écrit ne voulait plus
rien dire parce que c'était pas tour
nable si j'avais pas cette caméra
j'avais appelé pendant tout le tournage
les poissons déteste le vendredi et
s'étaient plus l'esprit du film quand le
film est sorti les distributeurs monde
et mais on croyait que c'était une
blague vous n'êtes pas sérieux quand
vous dites ça et ils m'ont dit non on
peut pas l'appeler les poissons des
tests de vendredi
on va l'appeler le maître nageur alors
âgé était peut-être un peu lâche
j'ai dit pompe si vous voulez moi j'ai
fait mon travail maintenant c'est à vous
et c'était une très mauvaise idée parce
que allant voir le maître nageur les
gens pensaient voir un film de jean
girault une comédie et il était déçu
parce que c'était pas ça tandis qu'ils
aillent y aurait eu peut-être pas plus
de monde mais au moins les gens qui
allaient voir les poissons des tests de
vendredi
il se disait c'est un film un peu
déjanté à tout ça n'est pas très grave
plus que dans n'importe quelle
discipline
le metteur en scène de cinéma est
vraiment le commandant du bateau ipaq
dans la marine c'est comme ça il ya des
fois des commandants qu'on trouve un peu
stupide mais on leur désobéit pas parce
que on n'a pas le temps au cinéma c'est
un peu la même chose on est obligé de
suivre parce que ça coûte cher une
minute de silence coûte très cher et
puis moi j'aime bien peu l'idée de se
confier à quelqu'un paye ont fait un
succès avec lui où on fait un bide c'est
pas dramatique on n'en meurt pas
l'artillerie et la de calculer les
angles la cavalerie celui de bien serrer
décembre voilà tout le secret de la
guerre nous sommes restés dans la joie
et la vertu des hommes ça me déplaît
quand on eût dit que peu c'est bien
parce que j'ai une jolie voix que je
pourrais dire de potins ce serait mais
c'est pas vrai mais je suis sûr que je
dis le bottin sans aucun intérêt c'est
pas la voix je pensais la voix c'est un
très bon c'est je pense pas que j'ai une
voix exceptionnelle puis elle est même
pas terrible je pense mais ça bon c'est
une chose mais j'ai travaillé quand
j'étais mais quand j'ai travaillé et la
voix c'est à dire et le timbre essayer
de placer la voix et le lac saint parce
que j'avais un très fort accent
méridional
je parlais comme ça c'est comme quand
des gens vous disent ah c'est bien ce
que vous faites vous avez une mémoire
formidable vraiment la mémoire c'est bon
c'est sûr qu'il faut se souvenir des
textes qu'on apprend mais c'est pas ce
qui est plus difficile si c'était pas
plus difficile que ça tout le monde sera
comédien parce que c'est pas tellement
divisée de la pompe des textes mais bon
les gens qui me disent ça ça me ça me
vexe quoi parce que j'ai travaillé plus
que pour apprendre le texte
alors ça me vexe non c'est pas grave
mais je trouve que c'est mal juger les
gens quoi
c'est juste après le service militaire
je reçus à la télé et ça ne marche pas
pour moi parce que j'étais ça faisait
trois ans que je n'avais plus tournée
j'étais un peu rayé du cinéma français
j'ai fait mon service militaire un peu
pendant la nouvelle vague
c'est à dire qu'a eu toute une nouvelle
génération d'acteurs très bien
d'ailleurs dont je ne faisais pas partie
quand j'ai raté ce train là et alors
quand j'en suis sortie c'était c'était
difficile pour moi c'était pour ça que
je suis en italie
ça m'avait complètement anéanti énorme
et on nous parlait pas de guerre on
disait il faut pas s'y fier en vain il
faut les pacifier l'algérie moi je si
j'avais eu vingt ans peut-être je
l'aurais cru j'y serais allé mais j'en
avais quand même 26 27 et c'est un âge
où on réfléchit un peu plus je me disais
mais il nous raconte des conneries c'est
pas possible on peut pas aller avec des
armes pacifier le pacifier un pays
et puis je connaissais un peu l'algérie
jeu j'étais allé un peu comme ça je
connaissais un peu les gens et et
j'étais enfin j'étais mal placé pour
accepter cette idée
si j'avais eu vingt ans peut-être ce ne
serait pas poser toutes ces questions le
milieu du cinéma italien dans les années
60 c'était au début des années 60
étaient tous des gens de gauche
alors où en était catholique où on était
de gauche mais de gauche d'extrême
gauche c'est-à-dire qui sortait vraiment
de l'occupation il sortait du fascisme
et y'avait n'y avait pas vraiment une
marge qu'il n'y avait pas un centre
gauche il y avait c'était aux
communistes ou fasciste elle est facile
c'était laid
catholique moi c'est un peu exagéré mais
c'était quand même assez sympathique et
tous les mettant celle que j'ai connue à
ce moment là c'était des tous des gens
de gauche vraiment de gauche par exemple
bertolucci été et est inscrit au parti
il a fait des films pour le parti il
était très très grosse quoi après
maintenant je sais pas maintenant qu'il
vient d'un mari qui doivent pas s'en
vanter
c'est un magnifique scénarise me
terrasse et sa parité de ya un gros
succès alors c'était un film qu'il y
avait beaucoup d'acteurs vedettes et
venez les colonels il y avait
mastroianni tony a dit cashman
c'est un film qui est vraiment été fait
pour être un film populaire
en plus c'est un film marquant c'était
un film qui voulait montrer la fin de la
comédie italienne quoi c'était un bon
film il y avait plein de choses peine
tous ces comédiens là qu'on appelait les
colonels en fait visiter quatre dans la
terrasse il en manquait un city sort des
sorts dit albert tout sort dé qui était
comédiens extraordinaires
c'était sûrement le moins intéressant il
était assez égoïste avare il disait
alors pourquoi avoir une femme ça coûte
cher une femme alors qu'ils gagnaient
beaucoup de fric
tonia si c'était un type très généreux
alors je sais qu'au début quand je ne
connaissais pas les autres me dise est
honnête il t'a pas invitée à bouffer
alors je disais non pas encore fais
gaffe il s'est fait gaffe parce qu'il
faisait très mal la cuisine mais il
faisait des cuisines pour vraiment
c'était une façon ingénieuse quoi voilà
et gassmann aussi était un type qui
avait un peu le culte de la culture
mastroianni c'était la mère est ce que
j'ai préféré des 4 il était généreux il
était intelligent il était modeste et
c'était tonique c'était magnifique
c'était enthousiaste on travaille
beaucoup on vous aime beaucoup d'heures
on arrive à tourner les x 15 heures 20
heures
c'était sans limites mais ça plaisir à
tout le monde on s'amuse et on perdait
beaucoup de temps
on perdait beaucoup de temps souvent le
tournage s'arrêter parce qu'il y avait
un machiniste qui a raconté une histoire
et on écoutait voilà alors que si on
faisait ça dans un chai français même à
cette époque là ça a été catastrophique
quoi
ça a été un des rares ou anciennes qui
n'a pas marché parce qu'il voulait être
un peu plus intelligent que les autres
alors à la fin dans les westerns le
héros moi je faisais le héros est le
héros il est toujours dans une situation
impossible et il s'en sort toujours
alors la dernière scène j'arrive et moi
j'étais blessé j'étais vraiment
sanguinolent et il y avait ils étaient
dix 10 méchant qui étaient cachées
partout dans une maison j'arrivais à
terrain découvert
et puis il y avait un reflet de je sais
pas quoi de soleil qui me faisait
comprendre qu'avec des personnes et le
avant que les types de tir moi je des
guinées part je vais tuer tous
alors j'ai dit au metteur en scène qui
était un type très intelligent et très
amusant comme ça je suis dit mais tu
crois pas quand même c'est pas sérieux
il faudrait quand même je peux je peux
pas faire ça enfin je peux le faire mais
mais c'est invraisemblable du crois pas
que ce serait bien que je reçoive une
balle que et que je tombe ce qui me tue
alors il m'a dit non mais c'est une
tradition ça les gens seraient pas
contents alors alors il me dit mais si
ça se fait plaisir on va le tourner
alors la tournée une fois puis on a
tourné la version qui était écrite et
puis je sais pas quelle folie lui a pris
il a monté sa version à moi et à cause
de ça le film n'a pas marché parce qu'il
était chouette à le film s'appelait
grande au silencio le grand silence
- business
c'est très sale comme encore fait
imaginons bien entendre n'orchestre de
l'opéra en tant que le racing va
s'accorder
c'est pas terrible ça dévoile pas un
truc vraiment extraordinaire j'ai tourné
avec le fils de michel audiard qui a été
un grands dialoguiste et alors jacques
audiard et ça paie c'est un mec
formidable intelligence formidable et il
m'a raconté qu'il avait 25 ans il était
prof de philo il a vu des études et des
profs de philo et un jour son père lui
dit mais arrête tes conneries de philo
de faire de la philo fait plutôt du ciné
vient faire du cinéma et du fric à
prendre ses mains on de dire ça non
mais c'était c'était avec l'homme de
père mais c'était pas c'était pas un
feuilleton c'était un reportage et un
journaliste un journaliste qui
l'interviewé l'homme de fer et l'homme
de fer et marché mais il marchait
toujours mal marché il marchait quoi il
était alors moi je sais pas tu trouves
pas ça bizarre toi tu sais y'a ya un mec
qu'il est paralysé et puis ensuite il
marche et c'est un acteur qui était sa
un acteur si tu lui dis de s'asseoir
dans un fauteuil roulant dessus mais le
cul dans un fauteuil roulant c'est son
métier c'est dupuis danser c'est un
comédien
parce qu'il n'ya qu'une aux ordres
déroulant c'est du bidon or à paris on
mettra moi c'est le championnat
il aurait pu prononcer un accord avec
des gens plus avec la nature moto il
aurait aussi fait connaître
alors dans ce film j'avais en fait
j'avais le rôle des gentianes et j'étais
engagé pour faire le rôle de jean yanne
et jean yanne été engagés pour faire mon
rôle
le rôle que j'ai fait dans ce film et
puis une semaine du tournage audiard a
dit ce serait quand même plus
intéressant si si vous changiez d'euros
lui alors j'ai dit à john tu veux
changer dit ouais si tu veux on a changé
et parce que c'est vrai que yann dans
mon rôle il aurait fait vraiment le
peigne dans maillot un bras dans le dos
quoi facile et moi j'aurais fait le sien
facile alors que ce que j'ai fait
c'était plus difficile mais c'est un mec
attachant j'ai eu bien génial
et puis c'est vraiment juste revin
formidables comédiens magnifiques un
magnifique il était jamais il le dépasse
et il était toujours en deçà de ce
qu'ils ressentent était magnifique
jacques audiard il disait yann il est
minéral
c'est à dire qu'il était tellement fermé
quoi que on savait vraiment rien de lui
il est minéral mais sensible sentais que
c'était un mec qui se livrait pas mais
qui était très sensible mais j'étais
très antipathique pendant ce film avec
même avec des gens que pour qui j'avais
beaucoup d'estimé comme comme jacques
audiard comme mathieu que j'ai mathieu
kassovitz que j'aimais bien aussi
même jean yanne 27 janvier il était lui
aussi très antipathique
on était très antipathique tous les deux
mais oui c'est vrai que ça compte
beaucoup et là c'était un rôle ou
vraiment je me disais il faut être
antipathique qu il faut être ferme et il
faut être antipathique
tu voulais pas tant d'argent et parce
que les pommes blessés je te l'aï
demandé
je te demandais quelque chose non c'est
pas grave j'ai carbone est surpris mais
c'est pas grave
caissière qu'est ce que tu veux dire
avec des yeux de clébard et aurait pu
merde regarde les hommes tomber j'ai tel
ou tel gt oui je je voulais pas faire
supporter à ma famille mes états d'âme
si on est comédien je crois quand même
qu'on peut il faut respecter les autres
faut pas les emmerder avec un autre
problème mais je pense que si on est
comédien on peut on peut faire ce à quoi
ça fait partie de notre métier tu
racontes on et interprète il ne faut pas
avoir de l'esprit critique sur ce qu'on
joue
moi j'aimerais par exemple j'aimerais
pas mais j'accepterais de jouer le
personnage de hitler si le contexte du
film était un film contre le nazisme
contre hitler et j'essaierai de le jouer
de son point de vue à lui c'est à dire
de le défendre
essayez de comprendre pourquoi il a fait
ça je pense que c'est le boulot d'un
comédien il ne faut pas surtout avoir un
esprit morale qui juge qu' d'hitler
c'est un monstre
c'est ce que je pense mais si je le
jouais j'essaierai de 2,2 de comprendre
pourquoi il a agi comme ça parce que
dans la vie jamais personne se dit je
suis un [__] je fais ça parce que je
suis un [__] les gens se trouvent
toujours des raisons de faire un truc
même si c'est pas bien
à
j'ai fait d'autres trucs d'autres
disciplines j'ai fait par exemple de la
course automobile
et quand on est sur une grille de départ
d'une course même une petite course 1
c'est incroyable on voit le jeu se
concentre raison ils sont prêts à
vraiment à jeter leur vie dans le dans
le dans la corse dans le jeu et je
trouve que les comédiens sur un plateau
de cinéma pas que les comédiens
d'ailleurs un peu tout le monde
ben on est un peu trop quand même
embourgeoisé un peu trop en fait les
choses un peu trop un peu trop sans
vraiment se donner complètement info est
cecce extraordinaire de jeu troupe de
pouvoir faire du ciné c'est une chose
formidable on devrait vraiment chaque
fois on devrait donner le meilleur de
nous mêmes il ya un metteur en scène je
dirait pas son nom est un survivant a
raconté qu'il avait tourné avec des
nerfs c'était un second rom et un joli
rôle et puis il avait tourné une scène
où il y avait beaucoup de figurants tous
un acte nerfs et à la fin de la journée
des nerfs est allé le voir et il y a dix
c'était un roman qui devait faire une
dizaine de jours de tournage
il a dit je dis parce je veux pas vous
faire de la peine mais je veux plus
tourner je veux pas finir le rôle à
l'autre l'idée mais commence à me vous
vous pouvez pas vous rendez compte ce
que ça coûte et il faudra le faire alors
il dit mais je vais payer pour en faire
la scène mais ça me plaît pas je veux
pas tout et c'est formidable un je
trouve qu'il n'ya pas beaucoup d'acteurs
qui ont ce courage denner jeu truc c'est
un immense comédien c'était un type
surtout d'une sensibilité incroyable
d'une imagination très tourmentée
sur mon très malheureux il a fallu avoir
beaucoup de bonheur dans sa vie mais il
était déchirée vraiment lui alors se
déchire et même pour des conneries
je m'attache à ne pas en rajouter ou ne
pas ne pas faire d'effet oui peut-être
mais c'est du je crois que c'est du
travail puis c'est une forme d'exigences
quoi oui c'est une forme d'exigences
mari ma vie disait des choses sur le
comédien disait il ya beaucoup de films
qui serait plus court si les comédiens
savait vraiment leur texte et souvent
ils prennent des temps parce qu'ils ont
un peu un problème de un problème de
textes alors ça leur permet de réfléchir
davantage les sentiments des temps qui
sont pas bien alors on se rend pas
compte parce que les comédiens ils ont
une certaine habileté et il enveloppe
tout ça et on a l'impression que c'est
un temps qui est justifiée mais souvent
il n'est pas justifié et c'est une
réflexion je trouve très très
intelligente mais elle était très
intelligente mari
enfin des choses que vous n'aimez pas et
que vous avez faire très bien par
exemple j'ai mis les mathématiques mais
on m'a fait faire du latin eh ben j'ai
plutôt pas été mauvais du tout en latin
naître aviateurs l'aéronavale c'est ça
que j'avais en tête et puis j'ai fait
dans la chaussure
mais là j'ai pas été mauvais non plus et
si c'est en fait j'étais très mauvais
très mauvais j'ai bouffé la boutique
menti
en fait non ce n'est pas tellement vrai
rien de vraiment indigne si je voulais
seulement trouver un imbécile qui
veuille de la maison et tous les kids et
monde est mal fait vous pouvez pas
vraiment savoir avant de vous mettre
debout sur une marche un peu
la piste ne va pas plus loin des courts
ya un truc vachement boom mois tout
fraîchement bon en fait vous êtes très
rafraîchissante
vous êtes vachement rafraîchissante
je devrais peut-être dire ça c'est
merveilleux d'être comédien et de
tourner des scènes comme ça ils sont
bien écrites avec des gens que qu'on
découvre c'est magnifique ça c'est un
preneur en ami chance folle et c'est
marrant parce que je les ai vus a pas
longtemps vincent vincent perez il est
venu ici et on a bouffé après il aime
beaucoup aussi ses films il aime
beaucoup cette scène m'a reparlé de
cette scène et puis même j'ai le béguin
un peu pour pour lui alors que je suis
pas du tout homosexuel dont le fais dans
la vie aussi
mais dans le film je suis un vieux
monsieur qui est quand même troublé par
parce ce pdg beau j'aime bien ça je
devais arrêter parce que j'aime de moins
en moins le signer mais je voulais plus
en faire déjà koshiro m'a demandé est
quand même ça me plaisait parce que le
sujet me plaisait plus cher ou un type
très très intéressant et en plus très
séduisant il a pris le temps il est venu
à la maison j'habitais ce moment là à
côté d'uzès une maison et il s'est un
peu installé et il a dit qu'il partirait
quand je serais d'accord c'était en même
temps c'était sympathique parce que
c'est quelqu'un d'important chéreau mais
c'est vrai il m'a séduit et il le manger
et buvait comme nous et ça ça l'a un peu
choqué parce que c'est vrai que nous on
mange beaucoup quand je dis nous c'est
ma femme et moi et nos amis et on mange
beaucoup ee et patrick qu'il était il
était il était de trouver utiliser mais
vous mangez tout temps tu as mangé pour
le plaisir quoi et on bouge au début
beaucoup font buvait que du vin mais on
buvait beaucoup
ça rend un peu abruti machin peu abruti
le site à part le vin rouge dit à sa
mère vous êtes la maman de cette
intéressante petite fille gaie et
nativement dans ma maison par la maison
on la tournée en province à limoges chez
dans un une maison de campagne comme ça
qui était qui pouvait être la maison
familiale de de ce type là est bien sûr
y'a les propriétaires et il était facile
un peu de ce il s'agit pas de les copier
mais il s'agit de comprendre vraiment
leurs problèmes tout ça c'est quand on
est comédien je pense est intéressant il
faut ayez aimé les gens et les observer
beaucoup et là il y avait un monsieur le
propriétaire delà de cette maison-là qui
ressemblait beaucoup à ce personnage
attachant et en même temps un peu
grotesque un peu ridicule non c'est vrai
j'ai bougé travailler beaucoup
moi je ne fais rien facilement il faut
que je travaille plus que les autres
parce que je suis peut-être pas très
doué j'ai besoin vraiment de travailler
malu malu chéri j'ai des baisers blindés
lèvres je tendais sur les yeux sur tes
cheveux faut partout partout des baisers
à faux les amours en cristal de baccarat
amour brisé en mille morceaux qu'elle
l'erié miraculeux pour être accommodé
sentant le vent se plaindre au dessus
des garrigues et ronfler la caserne où
cent mille fatigue un chien hurle à la
mort comme mon coeur saignant je perds
tout sauf l'honneur ainsi qu'à marignan
la nuit étant propice à ceux des qui
soupire j'ai goûté le meilleur je vais
goûter le pire mais je t'aime alou comme
on n'a pas aimé le loup elle s'est pas
rendu compte que l a été l'héroïne d'un
homme hervé d'une mère les histoires et
de grands poèmes je pense qu'elle ne
s'est pas rendu compte que j'ai connu à
la fin de sa vie j'ai connu des années
j'avais un ami suisse qui t'aime tant sa
mèche et desoutter qui sous un film le
petit fier mais clé en suisse et pour me
faire plaisir un soir humains m'a dit
viens dîner à la maison il y aura loup
alors j'étais bien sûr et puis j'ai vu
arriver une vieille dame avait dans les
80 un peu marche vraiment décolorés avec
un manteau en fourrure très maquillée et
puis bien sûr je lui parlais
d'apollinaire ah oui oui ce poète et
lutte
ou tu es fou vous avez jamais rien et
entre nous
alors j'ai dit non mais comment on suit
un petit trip enfin je m'en souviens
plus
il ya peut-être une petite chose alors
que lui les cris des dépôts m
complètement détruit amoureux sublime à
cette vieille école où on s'est rendu
compte
enfin c'était quand même loup c'était la
loue d'apollinaire
j'étais quand même bouleversé la mort
il cavale est derrière nous depuis des
mois et des mois l avais pas très envie
d'avoir une histoire d'amour avec lui un
jour il lui a dit je ne suis engagé à
faire la guerre
et alors loup quand elle a su ça elle a
été bouleversée parce qu'il lui a dit
que c'était à cause d'elle
en fait c'était un peu à cause d'elle
mais ce n'est pas complètement à cause
d'elle il avait la nationalité polonaise
et faire la guerre pour lui c'était une
façon d'être naturalisé français
alors elle est bien sûr a été
bouleversée elle est venue à nîmes et
ils ont vu une histoire qui a duré une
semaine
une histoire sur montre est
extraordinaire d'après ce qu'ils
racontent ça devait quand même pas être
banal
ils ont dû faire une vie surtout
érotique magnifique très importante donc
tyloo adoré je voudrais mourir un jour
que tu m'aimes
je voudrais être beau pour que tu
m'aimes
je voudrais être fort pour que tu
je voudrais être jeune jeunes pour que
tu m'aimes
je voudrais que la guerre recommence à
pour que tu m'aimes
je voudrais te prendre pour que tu
m'aimes
je voudrais te fais c'est pour que tu
je voudrais te faire mal pour que tu
m'aimes
je voudrais que nous soyons seul dans
mon petit bureau près de la terrasse
coucher sur le lit de fumerie pour que
tu m'aimes
après il a essayé de la revoir mais elle
voulait plus et finalement à la pâte et
menteurs quand elle lyon c'était
y a rien entre nous puis elle dira oui
elle brouille peut-être qu'il ya eu une
petite chose aujourd'hui
pour elle c'était une petite chose pour
lui c'était la fin du monde c'était
vraiment un truc extraordinaire
la guerre au début à la fin je crois
qu'il l'aimait plus du tout et qu'il
était assez désespérée de cette guerre
mais au début il a trouvé très gai c'est
vrai que ça a dû être pour un poète pour
un type qui voyait le les bombardements
un peu comme des feux d'artifice qui
enjolivent est ou celle qui était en
même temps très exalté ça a dû lui
plaire énormément et dans les laiteries
bhl il lui dit mais ne t'inquiète pas je
serai de retour dans quinze jours c'est
fini ça va pas durer
c'est ce que ce qu'il pensait est ce que
je crois penser tout le monde à ce
moment-là il pensait que c'était une
guerre qui allait s'arrêter très vite
comme on pense chaque fois comme ils ont
dû penser à la guerre de cent ans
et quand tu seras à vielle oma jeune
beauté lorsque l'hiver viendra après
tombé l'été lorsque mon nom sera répondu
sur la terre en entendant nommé
guillaume apollinaire tu diras il
m'aimait et enorgueillir a alors ouvre
ton coeur
dumazeau vertébrale
à
l'idée vient de mari c'est marie
vraiment qui est un jour m'a dit on
devrait faire ça il est certain que oui
j'aime beaucoup de poètes et avec marie
en échange et d des poèmes d'apollinaire
main échangée aussi d'autres poètes
oui c'est vrai qu'on aurait pu en faire
d'autres mais bon est-ce que c'est
tellement intéressant là il ya en plus
de la poésie en plus des textes il ya un
peu une ossature veut dramatique quand
même parce que c'est la guerre c'est
l'amour c'est une histoire malheureuse
tout ça c'est assez théâtrale quoi sans
être follement spectaculaire c'est quand
même un peu théâtral quoi ça nourrit
on
et
elle doit faire la 100ème pièces que je
fais et je crois que j'ai jamais entendu
ce à quoi il ya une telle une telle
l'écoutent magnifique
même les gens quand ils ont envie de
tous et on sent que c'est un drame ils
sont malheureux quoi ils se retiennent
de tous et enfin voilà c'est ça c'est
très très émouvant et ça vaut la peine
même s'il y avait que 10 personnes comme
ça dans la salle je serais quand même
content que je trouve que ça vous
rappelle que qu'on se déchire pour leur
donner ce qu'on peut leur donner c'est
un grand bonheur ça au lounge c'est
l'amour ou mon esclave en fuite
notre amour qui connut le soleil pas la
pluie fut un instant trop court la mère
ne regardait de son eid andré glauque et
les orangers d'or fructifiait pour nous
il fleuriste encore et j'entends la voix
rauque des canons allemands crier sur
mon mail on appelle de la tranchée au
loubard aux atroces et du toujours fâché
avec des yeux de plans au loup damon
enfants baiser de folie je te prends
pour toujours dans mes bras
ma jolie
non
en
on arrête ça vous embête pas
on
oui